bei unseren nachbarn ist das
herkömmliche parteiensystem letzten
sonntag quasi verstorben wir schreiten
die frankfurter börse zu albrecht
humboldt albrecht wie würde denn da auf
dem frankfurter parkett der erste teil
der präsidentenwahl aufgenommen eine
voranfrage oliver sie wurde der sieg von
makro hier an der börse aufgenommen
nun lassen sie es mich so sagen
[Musik]
kurz gesagt wer musik haben hier recht
gut an
der dax zum ersten mal über 12.400
punkte rekord also wenn ein mann den dax
so hoch krieg dann kann das kein
schlechter mensch sein der ist gelernte
investmentbanker einer von uns also also
auch die sogenannten märkte sind
erleichtert wenn es marine le pen nicht
schafft wegen islam hass rassismus und
so eine synthetisch islam hat und
rassismus in den märkten stiegen aber
die ihre lippen will die rente ab 60
da es bei mir feierabend europa und wer
dich europa sagen deutschland will dass
alles so bleibt wie da muss auch keine
eu enger zusammenwachsen das ist einfach
ein schöner großer absatzmarkt für
deutsche produkte ende die herbert wir
können nicht ernsthaft einfach so
weitermachen
unser lohn dumping schade zum beispiel
nachweislich den franzosen französische
fleisch hersteller bauern die werden
ruiniert durch deutschen niedriglöhne
damit können die nicht konkurrieren ja
ja gut da haben sie natürlich recht
einerseits andererseits 12.000
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das volk
natürlich müssen wir auch was lernen aus
der frankreich bereits natürlich klar
aber was denn konkret vielleicht doch
ein großes europäisches
investitionsprogramm weil wir endlich
einsehen dass in europa von denen nur
wir deutschen profitieren nicht
funktioniert in europa funktioniert doch
super aus dem markt erfolg habe ich was
völlig anderes gelernt du kannst
heutzutage aus dem stand als politiker
durch straßen und deshalb können wir
jetzt auch eine partei bitte natürlich
ich hab doch alle voraussetzung genau
mag ich bin sowohl links als auch rechts
ich stehe verteufelt gut aus und ich
habe schon wieder kontakt zu meiner
alten französischlehrerin aufgenommen
[Applaus]